now to the ongoing turmoil in cuba and
haiti president biden is contemplating
his next move and considering
how to back up his words of support with
action
among the questions what role the u.s
should play in assisting them
christina raffini has the latest from
the white house christina good morning
good morning dana well while his
predecessor drew criticism for allegedly
calling haiti an expletive
president biden raised eyebrows this
week referring to cuba as a failed state
but both countries are causing problems
for the administration
which wanted to focus its foreign policy
on countering russia and china
not dealing with crises 90 miles off the
florida coast
days of anti-government protests
followed by government crackdowns and
arrests across
cuba have led to the inevitable question
what if anything is the u.s going to do
about it at this point it's basic human
rights
quarantine lockdowns food and medical
shortages and a spike in coveted cases
have prompted widespread outcry
cuban americans are urging the white
house to take action
i have a lot of families still left in
cuba and a lot of family that still
haven't heard from
there are a number of things that we
would consider doing to help the people
of cuba
the administration has not signaled it's
ready to relax the trade embargo
which the cuban government blames for
the country's economic hardship
[Applause]
and even allowing americans to wire
money back to their families in cuba
known as remittances comes with
complications
i would not do that now because the fact
is it's highly likely that the
regime would confiscate those
remittances or big chunks of it
meanwhile in haiti an estimated quarter
of the nation's economy comes from those
remittances
the government's request for american
troops to help stabilize the country
after the assassination of president
giovanna moise
has been denied it's still not clear who
ordered the attack or why
nor is it clear exactly who is supposed
to be running the country
on friday hundreds of supporters
gathered to greet former haitian
president jean-betrant achistide
as he returned from seeking medical
treatment in cuba
ousted in a coup in 2004 ah is a popular
but polarizing figure
and a potentially volatile addition to
the political powder keg
in port-au-prince now the white house
has sent a team of state department
advisors as well as federal agents to
aid haiti in that investigation
and we asked the white house if in
addition to cuba it considers haiti or
any other country's failed states
we did not hear back how about that
christina thank you